hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel I'm sorry this video is coming
out a little bit later than I would have
liked uh to tell you the truth I
actually had a company dinner last night
which I got pretty drunk at and uh I was
fully wearing a onesie out cuz it was
Halloween and I was thinking like oh
this would be such a good time to film a
video I'm hammered and wearing a onesie
uh but unfortunately I got back and then
I I was pretty cold and and had to poop
and go to bed uh but nonetheless uh
today we will be talking about TCP
versus UDP and unfortunately I am stone
cold sober for it anyways hopefully by
the end of this video you'll know what
flow control and congestion control is
and know I'm not referring to the
that I took last night so anyways let's
go ahead and get into it all right so my
computer basically just blue screened as
I just started to try to record so that
sucks but uh here we go again so today
we are covering TCP vers UDP like I
mentioned and these are both acronyms
TCP being transmission control protocol
UDP being user datagram protocol and the
point is that there are both ways of
effectively sending messages over the
Internet or not necessarily ways but
they're protocols in order to you know
allow to have a standard for how we're
actually going to send packets over the
network and so those are going to work
on an IP network which just means that
computers have some sort of standardized
address and we can send those packets to
them using that address and of course if
these weren't a little bit different
from one another we wouldn't be talking
about them so let's talk about how they
are different well let's go ahead and
start out by talking about UDP so think
of UDP as super Bare Bones basically
you've got node one over here you've got
node two and basically all we do is say
you know I've got this address X let's
send packets there and UDP just goes
ahead and does that and as a result of
it being so Bare Bones UDP is super
simple it's super fast and the one kind
of slight guarantee that it does offer
about the data is you know if you've
heard of check sums basically it is
extra metadata per packet uh that allows
you to tell if the packet data has been
corrupted or not so it includes those as
well but other than that you really
don't get too much out of UDP uh it's
pretty simple and as a result it is fast
uh the one thing it is compatible with
is multicast which is you know for
example if I have three different nodes
over here blah blah blah blah blah one
node can very easily send a single
packet and it could be routed to all of
these places so you'll see multicast use
occasionally as well in certain
applications of course UDP as it is so
simple doesn't really give us any
guarantees about our data and
additionally you can pretty much just
send as many packets over the network as
you want so let's now talk about TCP
which tries to address these issues so
TCP kind of most importantly about it is
that it is a reliable two-way broadcast
and so what that means is that basically
we've got two nodes over here node one
node two like
before the first thing that they're
going to do before they can even start
communicating with one another is is
rather than just allowing messages to be
sent without the receiving node ever
like accepting that it's open to them in
TCP you must first perform a three-way
handshake and the three-way handshake is
pretty simple basically you've got node
one which I'll call the sender and node
two which I'll call the receiver even
though it is by directional they can
both communicate with each other one of
them has to initiate the handshake and
the handshake is initiated by sending
this type of message called a sin with
something over here with an X in this
case which I'll call the sequence number
for example X could be like 100 so what
node 2 is now going to do the second
step in the process is it's going to
respond with an act saying hey here's
the sequence number of my
acknowledgement in this case it's x +
one saying the receiver expects that the
next message it's going to receive will
have a sequence number of x + one and
then also what it's going to say is here
is another sin on my end with the
sequence number of
Y and then of course uh the sender is
going to acknowledge that with its own
sequence number saying y + one meaning
that when the receiver now sends packets
back to the sender the next message that
it sends should have a sequence number
of y + 1 so basically after that again
they can communicate with each other and
the sequence numbers are very important
here which we will start to talk about
because they guarantee that we can have
reliable delivery so TCP does reliable
delivery uh via two different methods
One is using sequence numbers and the
other is timeouts when we never receive
any acknowledgements so the
acknowledgements play a important an
important part here so imagine we have
our sender over here and our receiver
and the first thing that the sender does
is send a message with sequence number a
the receiver is then going to
acknowledge that because it receives
that message with A+ 1 saying the next
message that I get it should have
sequence number A+ 1 so let's go that
the sender listens to that and now it
sends a message with a+1 and it sees
from the receiver that it gets back an
acknowledgement with a+1 this is an
issue
because if the receiver had really
gotten this message it would have sent
an acknowledgement of
a+2 should be A+ 2 but if that's not the
case then the sender knows that the
receiver never got a+1 and because we
want to have reliable delivery here we
want to make sure that all the messages
we're sending to the receiver are
actually received and processed and so
what the sender would then do in this
case is it would send another message
again with a+1 wait until it hears back
A+ 2 and then it's good to go to start
sending more messages so that's how we
can do this with sequence numbers
another thing that TCP does for us is
use timeouts because we're not always
going to receive an acknowledgement
sometimes the network is just literally
broken so that example would look
something like this over here first
thing that we would do on the right is
send message a or message with sequence
number a and then of course we wait for
an acknowledgement but it just never
comes in and So eventually we're going
to time out you know maybe it's a couple
seconds maybe it's a few hundred
milliseconds who knows um but eventually
what we're going to do do is then send a
again and once we receive our
acknowledgement we're good and we no
longer have to keep retrying to send
that packet over and over and over again
now of course this could obviously
become very spammy you know we don't
want to just send a ton of data over the
network if our timeout is uh you know
continuing to get hit over and over and
over again and so one thing that TCP
does is use exponential back off so you
know we might start by waiting 5 seconds
but then afterwards we'll try to wait 10
seconds then 20 because obviously if
we're just sending a bunch of packets
over the network if our receiver is down
or something we don't just want to SP
the network that would be
bad speaking of spamming the network
we're now going to be talking about flow
and congest congestion control because
this is one of the other big things that
TCP actually does for us so even though
they're very similar um on a surface
level they are slightly different flow
and congestion control and so flow is on
the left here I don't know why I can't
pronounce congestion today but that's
how it goes so let's imagine that we've
got our sender and what it's doing is
basically sending two inflight mess
mesages that haven't yet been received
by the receiver node so the way that
things work is that every single
receiver every you know computer
generally connected to a network in
general has some Network buffer right
over here and let's say that it has a
size of 10 well it gets to the point
that uh you know if we send more
messages than there's space available in
the network buffer we're going to start
having some problems we might either a
start blocking the network uh packages
are just going to get dropped or we
might even overload the receipt reer and
that could all be bad so the gist is we
want to keep track of basically how many
messages are in flight and then not send
any more than that so for example
because these guys are in Flight we
would now say oh uh we've got size of
eight left because that's 10 minus two
we can send eight more messages before
this network buffer is out so basically
now once the receiver acknowledges these
messages it can basically say oh you
know I've got 10 left in my network
buffer and then this guy can readjust
back to
10 and so that's how we would stop uh
you know the network buffer getting
overloaded that's called flow control
okay the other thing is congestion
control so this is where instead of you
know overloading some Network buffer
like we have over here what we would
actually be doing this time is
accidentally overloading the network so
let's imagine that we start by having
some window right and the window is
basically again how many inflight
messages we can have let's say the
window is currently size 2
and so as you can see right now we've
got one inflight message out of two and
maybe let's go ahead and send another so
now we've gotten two out of two and then
you know we end up getting
acknowledgements for both of
them and everything looks good and so
what uh TCP will actually do for us is
it'll say hm you know what it actually
seemed fine that we had two inflight
messages at once we didn't really see
any issues in terms of traffic or
latency of response or anything like
like that maybe we can actually increase
our window a little bit now all of a
sudden we can send three inflight
messages at
once and so for what it's worth you know
I I talk about this kind of vaguely here
because there are many different
algorithms to determine you know is a
packet actually delayed or not because
you can't really ever objectively be
sure whether it's due to the network
itself or something else but at the end
of the day the point is we slowly creep
up and increase this window from two to
three to four and that's known as
additive increase and let's say we get
to four and then all of a sudden our
sender realizes hey wait a second you
know what four messages is way too big
for the network to handle uh we're
really going to start killing our
response times if we keep having this
many inflight messages what it'll do is
as oppose to just going back to three
it'll drop the size off really quickly
and divide by two back to two oops over
erased there but the point is when we
add to the size of our window we do it
you know just by one at a time time and
when we decrease the size of our window
we do it multiplicatively or
exponentially which is called aimd
additive increase multiplicative
decrease so hopefully that makes sense
the point is we want to be very careful
when we're making that window bigger and
then the second we see any signs of
things going wrong we really go back
quickly okay so hopefully that makes
some sense basically the gist is here
that UDP is super Bare Bones TCP on the
other hand offers us a lot of nice
features typically we want to be using
those nice features because we want all
of our packets to get to their
destination we don't want to overload
the network or Our receiver node but at
the same time there are some Niche
applications where UDP just makes more
sense besides something like multicast
we have a lot of realtime applications
where getting the data there as fast as
possible is super important and if we
were to drop an intermediate packet that
wouldn't be a huge deal so for example
let's say you know I'm making a video
call with my friend and I happen to drop
a frame well I don't really need that
frame back 4 seconds later it's not
going to make sense anymore it's fine if
it's just dropped it's overall going to
keep things faster same goes for things
like stock prices I really only care
about the most recent one not the one
from one second ago and also video games
kind of same idea as video calls like if
I already lost the frame getting it back
4 seconds later isn't going to do me
anything good so again TCP generally
speaking reliable but slower and so you
know use it for your typical web app but
there are some particular times where
UDP is going to make a little bit more
sense anyways guys I hope this was a
useful video I will probably be posting
it this weekend cuz I'm actually going
to be out of town so I'm not sure I'll
be able to post too but uh yeah have a
good one and I will see you all soon